the jurgen experience this really gets
old people um for um
what i would say are obvious reasons
whether it's immune system whether it's
lack of vitamin d where it's being shut
up whether it's a
um lowered cholesterol
i mean we haven't you know even talked
about what happens with all of the
statin drugs that people are taking to
lower their cholesterol well high
cholesterol is active
actually protective for something like
this um so you could predict
that a lot of older people were going to
die
if they weren't well protected we talk
about that for a second so statin drugs
the the idea is you're lowering
cholesterol because people have high
cholesterol the
high cholesterol puts them at a higher
risk of heart attack and stroke
not really not really but i mean we can
talk about that too that's the irony
that
it gets confusing right because some
people will argue
that it's the balance of ldl and hdl
and that cholesterol is actually
essential for production of
sex hormones and a lot of other things
that the human body requires a lot of
things it's probably the most important
hormone
cholesterol is probably the most
important molecule in the human body if
you really were to parse it
vitamin d sex hormones it's a working
molecule on a lot of
cell membranes and uh to think that we
i mean the body is so important the body
makes like 1 300 milligrams a day
regardless of what your cholesterol
intake is from food
so in my mind the notion that we would
um take this
amazing molecule that is basically
life-giving in in many regards and
vilify it and then
take drugs to lower it uh
which if you look at the research and
i wasn't planning on going down this
path today but if you look at the
research on
cholesterol and heart disease over the
past 20 years it's shifted everything
away from cholesterol being the
proximate cause of heart disease
cholesterol and saturated fat
are not the proximate cause of heart
disease it's oxidation and inflammation
cholesterol is involved in the repair of
damage to the tissue
and as a result people get because of
the oxidation and inflammation there's
cholesterol that's in the plaques and
things like that but
but i think many many doctors i'm going
to say the preponderance of doctors now
agree that cholesterol isn't the bad guy
that people made it out to be and and if
you look at other
other studies cohorts of people who've
had um cholesterol of
like 1 30 and lower or
200 and above the all-cause mortality
you die of
everything else at a much greater rate
with low cholesterol than you do with
high cholesterol
the only difference is the the cardiac
outcomes
um and it's not even death it's just
cardiac events is a little bit higher in
the in the higher group
and what what is it about
cholesterol that why why did cholesterol
become the bad guy why did it become
the boogeyman um
you know i does it have to do with the
hurt hey tinder are you there yeah does
it have to do with when they
when the sugar industry paid off those
scientists to
uh put push the blame on the saturated
fat yeah i mean
um a lot of this goes back to i'm not a
conspiracy theorist
you know i'm not uh i think most people
at the top are too greedy and stupid to
organize into a cabal right so i'm
thinking
how did this happen in terms of the
collective conscious
so mistakes were made early on whether
it's ansel keys and i know you've had a
lot of people on the show talking about
ansel keys in the
in the seven uh country study um
could you explain that real quick for
people oh just this this scientist
uh in the um 60s i guess
around then uh ansel keys had done a
study looking at
saturated fat intake uh of um
and heart correlated with heart disease
in different countries and and found
um at the end of the day he found that
there was a correlation between high
saturated fat intake
and heart disease but then later on you
find out that he looked at 32 study
32 countries but picked the seven that
fit his
his paradigm mostly so that was you know
i don't know if you've had gary tobbs
or nina on the show but you know they've
all everyone has sort of beaten this one
to death so the
the idea was that that was the sort of
the start of it
and then um mcgovern
and his committee when he was with the
uh you know
overseeing the us department of
agriculture and and trying to create the
first food pyramids
was convinced by pritikin that because
mcgovern's wife had had a good
experience at the pritikin longevity
center which was a zero fat
sort of protocol
so that politicized that enough that
they decided to vilify
fat cholesterol over the years has been
more vilified because of studies done
again correlating higher cholesterol
with
with higher incidence of heart issues
and the drug industry certainly got on
that and that's why statins came
to the forefront statins themselves
though have a host of pretty
bad side effects i'm i'm telling you i
mean i think
until some of these other things have
come down recently
i would say that this statins are
probably the greatest hoax ever
perpetrated on the american public in
terms of medicine
but that's just me i'm not a doctor i
just do a lot of research and reading
so the idea that we would yeah so to
your point statins
tend to um you know there are
uh brain fog issues liver issues uh uh
muscle
weakness issues um one of the things
that statins do is they
uh decrease the amount of coq10 that
your body produces
because it's a similar pathway and so
you have to you should generally take
supplemental coq10 with statins a friend
of mine said that when he did the
original when he was
researching statins one of the original
patents on statins
inclu acknowledged this deficiency of
coq10 and so it included coq10 and the
drug but coq10 was so expensive to make
they just cleaved off that part of the
patent anyway
um where i don't know where where that
was headed but
um you know we're the if we're talking
about covid
it appears that high cholesterol higher
cholesterol is protective
for infections like covet but how is
that the case because
one of the problems with covid is people
with high obesity obese people
tend to have a really hard time with
covet in fact 78
of the hospitalizations they found out
that those people were obese i would
imagine a lot of those obese people also
have high cholesterol okay but look at
all the other factors so you know
if if we're against a big factor in
terms of overall diminishing of your
immune system
yeah exactly what i would say i would
say that
from you know what i've read um
blood glucose so you know diabetics are
much more susceptible to covid because
this virus tends to like higher blood
sugar
if you have a pre-existing systemic
inflammation
not a good sign uh vitamin d probably
you know
across the board the greatest predictor
of your survivability of coke yeah
so if people have been locked inside all
you know all year and haven't had any
sun exposure
their vitamin d status has been
compromised
tremendously catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience